hello everyone and thank you for
tuning in to our virtual session i'm
delighted to be here today with my
co-panelists
uh professor shifu chang heng ji and
kaiwei
kaiwei chang uh we're going to discuss
the current state of
conversational ai and natural language
understanding
um some of the interesting problems that
my colleagues are working on here at
amazon will be the topic of our
discussion as well
uh we'll start with a quick panel
discussion and then move on to
q a where we'll take questions from the
audience
uh shifu heng and kaiwei are all part of
the
amazon uh scholars and
visiting academics programs
these programs allow university faculty
to come work full-time work
part-time or full-time at amazon they
can work on hard real-world problems
they can see the impact of their work on
customer facing
products etc
these programs are just part of our
portfolio of academic programs
of course we bring in graduate students
for internships
year round there's also the amazon
research awards program
under which we provide funding for
university researchers to do
research projects at the university with
their phd
graduate students postdocs etc
there's also the alexa prize which is
near and dear to my heart
the alexa prize is our flagship
competition program through which we
seek to accelerate
advances in conversational ai with a
particular emphasis on social bots
and these are university teams in the
alexa price competition
that get to see their social bots
directly interact with alexa users
so with that is a brief introduction and
context um i'll ask my co-panelists to
introduce themselves uh we'll start with
uh kaiwei
hi i'm kari jong so i'm an assistant
professor at ucla
and visiting academia at amazon so i'm
interested in
developing fair and accountable language
processing technology
i'm excited to join amazon and work with
the alexa team
on real world problems to enhance the
experience of our users
through my research
thanks kaiwe hang hi
my name is hanji i'm an amazon scholar
i'm also professor at the computer
science
of uiuc and i have been working on
information introduction research for a
long time since i was undergrad student
so although i think
the research environment in academia is
more like every tower
we get a problem from our government
sponsor we work on very small and
clean data we deliver something for
evaluation
and then we move on so i have been
always wondering
whether we really have solved the
problems for real water data so that's
why i
joined amazon scholar and the other
reason is of course
i have been working with these great
colleagues like professor chang
plain and i always admire uh
kaiwei and other people so i'm really
grateful
to have this another opportunity to
continue working with them
and uh we're grateful to you for joining
amazon hang
shifu yes thank you sam
okay i'm shifu chen a faculty member
in electrical engineering and computer
science at columbia university
and sorry we cannot see everyone in
person but it's great to be on this
panel
i'm also happy to be an amazon scholar
working with
my colleagues here in alexa ai
organization
and also very happy to mention that
recently amazon and columbia
jointly launched a very exciting center
on ai technology and i am very fortunate
to have opportunity to serve as the
inaugural inaugural director of the
center
the experience at amazon will give each
of us
a unique opportunity really to explore
new research that's not possible in
university and for example myself in
amazon right now working with colleagues
involved in research
developing new multi-modal multi-sensory
features
really can help us to enable more
natural
and more productive experience when
users in the future interact with not
only
alexa any future generation of
intelligent ambient devices no matter
you work at home or work in the office
or you transport in a car or any other
setting i would love to share
more and discuss more in the panel today
thanks and we're all looking forward to
that um we'll actually move on to a
discussion
of your perspectives bridging sort of
these two twin worlds of academia and
industry
i think also ai is in this sort of
really interesting phase where there's
exciting work in academia and there's
really exciting work in industry
and this opportunity to bring it all
together is something i'm sure the
audience is
very keen to hear about before we move
to that just a quick
reminder to the audience we will be
taking
sort of questions from you but the
easiest way might be for you to enter
your questions in the chat room as
this discussion progresses and then
we'll when we get to them we'll start
taking those questions
um back to you shifu you've worked for
many decades in the area of multi-modal
and multi-sensory ai in fact
we we met each other as part of a of a
government program
in multimodal uh research uh we all
agree
multimodality is an increasingly
important aspect of conversational ai
and at the recent the recent devices
launch event in september
our head scientist rohit prasad shared a
demo
of alexa's new natural turn taking
capability something with which you're
very familiar
uh i think it would be great for the
audience to hear from you about how
you're applying your research at alexa
what's unique about this opportunity you
use the word unique how what's unique
about the opportunity
to continue your research in this field
here at amazon
yeah thank you prem for bringing up this
exciting
topic uh yeah i worked on this topic for
several decades
but that makes me feel hoaxed but my
advisor in the past would say you have
to move on but now this
air this topic really gets so exciting
with so many new ideas and new
opportunities
uh particularly in how do you make the
whole human agent interaction more
natural more intelligent and multimodal
multi-sensory as premier league player
very clearly here
human interaction even though we are on
a zoom right now okay human you can
actually use
the full spectrum of the multimodal
multi-sensory 2 and linguistic
audio video even in the surrounding
context to communicate and collaborate
if we take a look of the video that's
shown by
dr rahid prasad in the launch events
in september and maybe we can take a
look at the video now
the ability to interact with ambient
devices
by just speaking the wake word alexa and
issuing your request
is delightful but that's not how we
interact as human beings
our conversations are far more
free-flowing
very less structured we often don't use
each other's names
we talk over each other's and we speak
simultaneously
two years ago we introduced the
capability of follow-up mode
that allows you to issue back-to-back
requests to alexa
without using the wake word today i'm
excited to bring natural turn taking
that enables customers to interact with
alexa at their own pace
without using the wake wood on every
turn and
even multiple people can join the
conversation
i can speak to you about this for hours
but let me just show it to you because
it's much simpler to understand the
concept
i'm getting hungry how do you feel about
ordering pizza tonight
i could definitely go for some pizza
awesome alexa
join our conversation okay let's talk
i want to order a thin crust specialty
pizza from mike's pizza
today mike's pizza has the following
specialty pizzas
three cheese delight meat lovers veggie
supreme
pepperoni party okay what size
medium okay so i have a medium
thin crust veggie supreme do you think a
medium is gonna be enough
i'm hungry i'm starving change that to a
large pizza
okay so i have a large thin crust veggie
supreme for 18.75 cents
would you like to place the order yes
okay
completing your purchase with amazon pay
you'll receive an email confirmation
you want to watch a movie while we wait
that sounds good let's see what's
playing
what movie do you recommend how about
the goldfinch starring oaks fagley
who directs it the goldfinch is directed
by john crowley
what do you think is it a good movie
the goldfinch has a rating of 6.3 on
imdb
based on 14 000 votes play the trailer
playing the trailer now as you saw
to enable this experience we had to
solve several challenges
when people are talking are they talking
to each other
or is the conversation directed towards
alexa
and if it is directed towards alexa who
should alexa respond to
this required real invention
in multi-sensory artificial intelligence
that goes
far beyond natural language
understanding alexa uses acoustic
linguistic and even visual cues to
determine whether the request
is directed towards her once she
determines that it's indeed a request
directed at her
she uses the entire conversational
context to decide what's the best
response
or what's the best action to take
natural turn taking is a major step
forward
for enabling customers to interact with
alexa at their
own pace what i showed you today are
exciting advances in the field of
artificial intelligence
and they make alexa more natural more
conversational
and more useful for our customers in
their daily lives
okay so in this video you can see that
this maybe you feel there's nothing
unusual it's so normal
and that's the point right the human
interaction is so natural
and not only we understand what is the
semantic context
content being communicated and we
understand
how the communication conversation is
going now like who is directed
directing the conversation to whom and
when and how we should respond to the
conversation when is our term
and if you feel necessary to interrupt
you know when and how to interrupt using
multi-modal q
and we do this in a very natural way
without a very rich
turn control mechanism that's usually
what you see in today's
solution and very important we use
multimodal multi-sensory cue
so this uh opportunity work with my
colleague here and many other scientists
engineers in amazon
really truly exciting right you can
really combine what we do in academia
and then put in a real-world setting and
and apply to this customer needs
customer
upset science driven approach really
excited i'm very happy to
to be have opportunity to explore this
yeah uh thanks for that chief i have one
more for you actually um
uh you know one of the recent
initiatives that i'm
super excited about is the recently
launched
research center in new york that we
worked on together a joint effort
between colombia
engineering school and amazon
you're closely involved in in that
initiative
as you know we've committed to providing
the center
five million over the next five years
from amazon
to support research education and
outreach programs
uh at columbia we call it the columbia
center for ai technology right
and this center is a very important
example of
amazon's commitment to partnering with
academia long term
on fundamental research problems
addressing the hardest challenges in ai
ultimately with the goal to democratize
access to
uh the benefits of ai innovations right
what are your hopes and ambitions for
the center chief who i'm sure
students and faculty here are super
curious to learn about that
yeah thank you for bringing it up it's
really uh the edge of my heart too
and we have all devote our efforts to
not only scientific innovation but also
how to make
our effort has the highest impact and
combining
of the effort from academia industry and
community is really the right way to do
it
and thank you pram and your leader to
for your leadership and partnership
throughout this effort
would not have been possible without
your leadership and many efforts from
the friends from both sides
this new center represents my personal
opinion
represent a perfect model for university
industry collaboration
we support conversion projects that by
conversion project i mean combine
fundamental research in academia
as well as i repeat again customer
obsessed science
project in industry particularly in
amazon here to
improve the real user experience and for
example you provide
a support for collaborative research
project between academia and amazon
researchers
as well as the early stage fundamental
research study
from academia will support research for
a talent development with a two-year phd
fellowship support
and very importantly translates the
knowledge
and results into the community into the
society by
open source distribution by community
program
symposium open to the public and to me i
also feel very proud that new york
city area like many other regions my
colleagues here may complain
highlighted in new york city but it's
one of the areas that
is very efficiently growing and
developing ecosystem that's really key
and important for artificial
intelligence including
university entrepreneurs industry as
well as a government agency
and i think creation of this center is
very critical and very
timely to help us to contribute further
success of this ecosystem
yeah and we're uh delighted to partner
with
you all shifu on this thing thank you
uh hang um to you
uh you know for as long as i've known
you and it's a long time
you're you've you've sort of uh slowly
but steadily expanded your
uh technical uh scope of work um
but there is still been this
long-standing thread of information and
entity extraction
uh that has sort of uh tied your work
together over the years you've sort of
expanded into multilinguality
and multimodality and things like that
uh
so can you sort of share your experience
and like what brought you to amazon
what's been unique
uh over the close to about you know
seven eight months that you've been at
amazon in terms of
the work you've done what are you most
excited about to be engaged in at amazon
yeah sure so yeah it's so this is
my first project on making
entity resolution and the recommendation
more personalized basically so i want to
allocate to be our best friend
rather than just assistant so based on
my recent collaboration with the alexa's
entity resolution team we have been
really developing a very novel framework
for personalized anti-resolution
recommendation
so honestly before i join amazon i tend
to think that
uh interlinking solves the problem
because if we link
any entity from news to wikipedia we can
get more than 90
accuracy so after i joined amazon start
to realize the scale and the complexity
of this industrial applications really
present lots of unique new challenges
so let me talk about maybe a couple of
them so the first one is what
we usually call as a tail problem so
in in academic world we always have seen
those
you know important and popular entities
in news
politicians so you already know a lot of
them and
you you know about their properties and
there are a lot of information in
wikipedia articles so
in the industry applications for example
in alexa conversations people are
talking about
new and emerging entities you know
nothing about them
and you know very little about new users
so how can we handle this can retail and
it is
effectively we will need to aggregate a
lot of content
so we need to look at user's interest we
learn the implicit properties
entities and put them together into
heterogeneous graph
and then we can infer what they are
interesting in the future
so recently we have developed a very
novel framework that would connect to
users and entities
and then we can perform link prediction
so that we actually know what is
in behind the existing very scarce and
technology base we have also
dramatically expanded the entity
ontology you know from
academic award we care about the people
organization location
but now we actually expand that to much
larger scale tens of thousands in alex's
specific or hierarchy
and then we are very excited to discover
this kind of attributes
using multimedia features and the other
challenge i
feel really really interested in
interesting is the
correct genre transfer because we
usually work on very clean news data but
in alexa
we have the data coming from special
recognition a lot of noise
so how can we handle this can noise
make our system more robust that will
require a lot of joint modeling of
asr and anti anti-resolution
to uh joint influence and
also i'm really excited about the
cross-lingual chances of heart
so because that's my academic project
i'm working on many years
um how can we make english technology
working for other loyal source languages
so amazon alexa actually offers a very
unique
environment because many users they have
their own preferred languages
so our goal here is to be able to
identify information
from all the digital data in 300
languages
and aggregate aggregate them together in
a way that
user they can speak their own favorite
languages they can answer questions
they can initiate conversations and
alexa style can also
return results from other languages
so currently you know if you look at the
most successful uh multilingual
embedding methods in academic
we normally can reach up to say 76
f score for ndt progression this is
still much lower than
english and uh to be able to make this
kind of techniques
useful for commercialized world will
need to
incorporate all kinds of novel ideas to
automatically correct the noise data and
then
do cross-legal transfer in a much lower
cost
way so uh and finally the
the other exciting challenge i uh
identified only after i joined amazon is
this a
thing called localized entity
recommendation
for example if i ask her about a cat
alexa needs to figure out i'm talking
about my real cat
the animal or a cat
toy sitting in my bedroom so this kind
of uh
uh query will need alexa to be able to
localize entities in the user's
environment
and then we can generate a description
about these entities and then illustrate
the features using multimedia attributes
so all this will make the alexa much
more proactive and engaging
in a way that also can you know explain
their
recommendation to the users um so right
now we are trying to
expand expand our framework so that it
can handle
uh multilingual environment and make the
conversation more
engaging and we also have you know
work a lot on multilingual environment
so we are trying to
make that more effective gradually one
by one
so that it will be much more interesting
to a diverse use
group of users yeah thanks hank
you were talking about the performance
of this multilingual stuff
on open source data and you were saying
that the state of the art for
cross-lingual
even on open source data is too low
uh and as you pointed out commercial
applications the challenges can be even
greater so
a lot of work that needs to be done
there and making this useful but it's a
very exciting
uh area of work because it basically
puts the whole world within reach of the
whole world
which sort of is an exciting thing that
drives us
um uh you know kai i'm going to turn to
you
and and a topic that uh i know that you
care a lot about and it's one that i
also care about
uh fairness and ai uh it's become uh
a topic of popular conversation uh both
among
uh in academia in industry and even in
like society in general
and at amazon we believe that academia
has a crucial role to play in this area
uh by bringing in diverse perspectives
uh and multiple disciplines into the
conversation different equities into a
conversation
um to that end uh we
launched uh early last year uh this 20
million dollar collaboration or
partnership with nsf
uh to award grants uh to academic
research projects
uh focus on fairness and ai
at the end of last year early this year
nsf had selected the first 10 recipients
of the grants we funded them that work
is underway
we've also launched a fairness in ai
track in the amazon research awards
program uh
so coming back to your focus in fairness
in ai you've broken new ground in
fairness and natural language processing
i mean you've
helped to find that problem space in
many ways
tell us a little bit more about sort of
your work in this area
and what you see as sort of the key
challenges and exciting opportunities in
area
in this area in general sure yeah so
natural language processing
and artificial intelligent application
are everywhere in our life now
right so despite recent nlp progress
revolutionized the
failed and also data-driven model
achieved remarkable performance
in many applications so they want to
raise to discover
and exported social bias present in the
underlying data that they are training
on
so for example in our recent work we
analyze the bias
in language generation model we define
regard as a general social perception
toward
a specific demographic group and find
that a natural language generation model
reflect the general social perception of
a different demographic group
differently so as ai systems are
increasingly integrated into people's
daily lives and directly interact with
the end user
the system have a significant social
impact
so for example users of this system may
normally receive the bias information
so this may further enhance this good
perception
and steel type for certain populations
and users from the minority group
are more likely to be offensed by or in
a counter obstacle of using this
distance
and substantially lose their trust and
stop using this distance
the fiance in llp is essential as he
allowed
nlp technology to benefit everyone
and early in 2019 sorry 2018
nsf announced later to promote research
of dna's ethics accountability and
transparency for artificial
intelligence as this topic is aligned
pretty well with the endless
so as prin mentioned amazon is sponsored
and nsf has a program on promoting
venues in artificial intelligence
and in general viewers and effice has
been also recognized as a key sub area
in recent major conferences
like triple ai and acl so at amazon i'm
collaborating with a team lead by rahul
to find a way to detect bias in the
natural language processing system
in order to enhance the experience of
old user
through ensuring fearness and robustness
in this language processing technique
yeah i like the observation that
you know given how we approach
products um uh customers are central to
our
mental model of the world and customer
trust it takes uh
priority over everything else uh in in
what we do
uh thanks uh kawaii for that and thanks
in fact to all three of you for sharing
your
insights your observations
uh because we have to uh leave some time
for uh q a
uh so we'll do like one one more last uh
question to all three of you uh
you know we are less than a decade into
the deep learning revolution
right i mean 2011 is the date that we
all
usually like to cite as sort of the
starting year
um the pace of progress has been
tremendous
the volume of research has been
phenomenal
so given all that do you all feel
these are still early days or do you
feel
we have tapped most of the potential of
deep learning
and where do you see the field of
conversational ai headed next
we'll start with the hang sure yeah
um but i cannot estimate the age of
where deep learning is
i think people have different different
opinions but i think
uh for us you know in the future uh for
this particular project i really want to
make a conversational ai
more personalized in a more intelligent
and knowledgeable way
so when i say i want alexa to be my best
friend i'm really serious about that
maybe you know even
better than my own bestie because you
know best friends
human friends will grow apart but i
think alexa can
grow together with us so for example for
anti-recommendation we want to make
uh the system more explainable and
because only if you can explain the
recommendation you can make it more
convincing
and we also want to make the
representation more
knowledge aware so that uh the
conversation
generated conversation can be more
proactive and knowledge driven
so that you know it will be more
convincing and more engaging
i'm also interested in building a much
more effective multilingual multimedia
news recommender
so that you know you can actually
summarize the information
about the most important events
happening in the whole world
and this kind of summary should be
personalized for the user at the same
time with
other misinformation removed so that
will be that my gene goal in the future
awesome
kaiwei yeah and for me human
communication rely on social norms and
common sense
the recent progress in deep learning has
revolutionized conversational ai in many
aspects
however to bring the conversational ai
to the next level
i believe we need to equip other
machines to understand the social norms
and interact with a human properly so
more importantly
as a conversational ai now they are
interact with the end users
i believe we need to ensure the
accountability
of the system and ensure it works for
everyone
interesting shifu will
give you so the last word in this uh
opening uh session thank you
now i would love to go to the qa session
uh and and then listen to our audience
i know i think unless the future of ai
is
really fascinating right and say about
the knowledge in
cooperation and then kaiwe mentioned
about the social norm that's our
aspiration right so how do we
incorporate knowledge
into the model into the prediction
so and then how do we teach the model to
really follow
observe the human social norm so on the
knowledge part i think that's very
important i have been working on and
also following the
footsteps at hand and other people has
been pioneering in nlp and text
how do we incorporate structure
knowledge in
from different domain different sources
into
the the process of ai model including
extraction
understanding generation dialogue
recommendation
and incorporation of this structural
knowledge
have not really been possible so far
we have seen a lot of a prediction model
correlation model
but incorporation of the structure
symbolic knowledge into the deep
learning is fascinating
and it will allow us to explain how the
model work
right if you make a decision make a
prediction why is that
so it's not just based on a score
optimization
and how do we discover common sense that
kaiwe mentioned right
so common sense you can refer to
physical common sense
causal or even temporal
and many other allow you to do reasoning
so
how do we discover that and use that in
the deep learning model help us to
reason
besides this the other dimension i feel
very excited about is
this self-learning and generalization so
people start to talk about ai
or agi or generalizable ai
right so the today's ci is based on
large label data she provides learning
numeric
pattern coordination but we see some
exciting progress
within amazon and also in the scientific
community
self-learning with generalization
capability
it seems to be on her horizon that very
exciting
and we can try to pursue particularly in
the conversational ai area which involve
real-time interactivity with humans in a
loop
and that human real-time interaction
plot generalization
it's really exciting i'm not sure how
long it will take us to start
hopefully not another one or two decades
and we can make a concrete milestone in
progress
and that's why i really enjoy this
direction working with many of you and
hopefully we can have more discussion
with the audience oh yeah
uh exciting conversation uh as always
uh with all of you on the self-learning
stuff uh
i was thinking in the same september
devices event where we showed the
natural turn taking demo we also showed
uh
this teachable alexa demo where users
can directly
teach alexa some new concepts uh et
cetera to
you know words make her more personal
uh like be able to understand them uh
i'm excited as i'm sure all of you are
to be part of the ai community
uh you know charles west the former
director of the nae
national academy of engineering had once
said it's an unprecedented time of
opportunity to be in the field of
engineering
uh i i feel i can borrow that phrase
from him and say it's an unprecedented
uh time of opportunity to be in the
field of ai within the field of
engineering
uh but now uh on to uh q
a and let's see what questions we're
getting